yeah welcome to this video playing to
win Duane I'm not sure about the
pronunciation check the Bronstein Larson
Bishop e2 him quickly played I'm not
sure if this is mmm yeah I think I can
educate just play the the normal the
normal moves
I look good we're on kind of a kind of
the counter play yeah but c5 mc5 by why
deserve quite irritating
I castleknock c5 killer can actually
sacrifice I wonder taking here 95 or is
this completely completely idiotic yeah
come on I'm Chad try this i'm not i
didn't really calculate let's see okay
he's playing something entirely
different i was thinking about c5 of
course ok but what now yeah I cannot oh
maybe I can just play here I just quit
b3 it doesn't really help yeah but
anyway quit a7 I can just take c4 and
here maybe c5 myself yeah this should
should be kosher be quite okay so
nothing spectacular but playable
position may be fine with efore coming
Rock t3 is an important move
can be very important route III
guy could just take it a drug tier 3 if
it takes earth it takes c5 Arak t3
immediately
where do you do now Queen B 5 it's also
booth oh he's just giving up the Queen
didn't didn't think about that at all I
hope I hope it's not working now but
he's got very a very decent eye
coordination this is at least dangerous
in a practical game if not more when I
cannot go to this happen because of the
city 97 nonsense ah what deck all right
yeah i was losing material anyway
because of the awful piece coordination
maybe i'm getting a couple of pounds at
least
hmm
be three that's not so sure probably it
is very good for white but you still
need to coordinate your pieces hmm okay
he wants to go to d7
you can still go to d7 I cannot take you
for because of a mate you had this I
hoped that look the eighth but he can
even play Nancy phone ah what again
sometimes you really ask yourself what
why the heck am I playing this
yeah all right black resigned well yeah
I need to break obviously i'm pretty
sure that this there was something for
black heaven I don't really believe that
this is good for white rook to e3 and
stuff I don't know and now he just gave
away the Queen without any any neat idea
quidsi to was perfectly all right but
yeah that was it wasn't easy and I
immediately went wrong here this is this
is just awful awful crap just King b8
King b8 and Knight to c8 yeah I need F I
simply didn't see c5 I mean very easy
move I need to go here and then it's
simply it's simply a game room in white
has some play for the Queen but it's a
it's barely sufficient I mean something
like this covering and roop t8 coming I
mean es chances to hold it but it's a
it's only black you can play for
something him it's still a queen no but
ok I definitely needs a break thanks for
watching anyway